So we've all seen it.
When we load an older app
on our nice new device,
sometimes icons look really,
really blurry.
In these cases the app most likely
used a low-resolution asset for
a UI element that was
given a larger size.
An easy first step to improving an app
is to make sure it has a high-resolution
assets like this one.
Much better, right?
While you should generally
provide assets for
all these major density buckets, it's
normally okay to include just XHDPI or
XXHDPI assets, and let Android scale
them down or down-sample them.
It's not ideal, but
if you had to pick one,
provide the higher density assets and
not just the lower ones.
However down-sampling has risks.
There's a minor performance hit
when Android has to do scaling for
you on the fly.
Additionally, Android's down-sampling
algorithm is really optimized for speed,
not perfect scaling.
It doesn't look great at all if you have
to down-sample from a very large 16 by
16 hundred pixel graphic to
a small 200 by 200 pixel space.
The good news is,
there are lots of great tools out there
for automatically creating graphics for
all the major density buckets
when your creating you're app.
One example that's useful for
icons is the Android Asset Studio.
Check the instructor notes for a link.